♪ ♪
>> Laura: MR. PRESIDENT, WE
LEARNED NANCY PELOSI SENDING
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT NEXT
WEEK TO THE SENATE.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
>> President Trump: IT IS
RIDICULOUS.
SHE SHOULD HAVE SENT THEM A LONG
TIME AGO.
IT JUST BELITTLES THE PROCESS.
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE TO
IMPEACHMENT, IT'S LIKE I WAS
INTERVIEWED BY A VERY, VERY GOOD
WRITER, REPORTER, SOMEBODY THAT
YOU KNOW VERY WELL.
BOB WOODWARD.
AND THIS TIME I SAID, MAYBE I
WILL SIT DOWN.
BECAUSE NOBODY IS DONE MORE.
NOBODY COME IF YOU LOOK AT THREE
YEARS WITH THE ECONOMY, WITH
REGULATIONS, WITH THE TAX CUTS,
WE HAVE REBUILT OUR MILITARY.
OUR MILITARY WAS TOTALLY
DEPLETED.
OUR MILITARY WAS OLD AND
HE SAID, YOU KNOW, YOU DON'T
LOOK LIKE SOMEBODY UNDER
IMPEACHMENT.
AS YOU KNOW, HE SLIGHTLY COVERED
NIXON AND HE COVERED CLINTON,
BUT BOB WOODWARD SAID, YOU
ACTUALLY LOOK LIKE YOU'VE WON
EVERYTHING.
YOU LOOK HAPPY.
I SAID, I AM HAPPY.
SO MAYBE I'M WIRED A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT.
>> Laura: THE MANAGER'S
COMMITTEE WHEN YOU WOULD PREFER
TO SEE?
>> President Trump: WE HAVE A
TEAM.
WE HAVE A TEAM.
>> Laura: PUT HER IMPEACHMENT
MANAGERS.
>> President Trump: I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK A COUPLE OF PEOPLE
LIKE SCHIFF, WHY DID HE LIE?
WHY DID HE MAKE UP MY STATEMENT,
TOTALLY MADE IT UP.
BUT AGAIN, THE WHOLE THING
UNRAVELED WHEN I PUT IT IN THE
TRANSCRIPT BECAUSE IT'S ALL
ABOUT THE TRANSCRIPT.
IT'S ALL ABOUT THE PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE SAYING HE DID NOTHING
WRONG.
>> Laura: HOW LONG DO YOU
THINK THIS WILL LAST?
>> President Trump: IT DEPENDS
IF THEY HAVE A TRAIL, PROBABLY A
FEW DAYS, A WEEK.
UNLESS WE WANT A BIGGER TRAIL
WHERE WE BRING IN THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER WHICH I WOULD
LOVE TO DO.
I WOULD LOVE TO BRING IN THE
INFORMANT WHO DISAPPEARED AND
THE SECOND WHISTLE-BLOWER WHO
DISAPPEARED.
I WOULD LOVE TO BRING IN THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
WHY DID HE BRING IT UP THERE?
HE SHOULD HAVE NEVER DONE IT.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO SEE THE CALL.
HE DID NOT WANT TO SEE THE CALL.
HE TOOK THE WHISTLE-BLOWER WHICH
IS A FRAUD, THE WHISTLE-BLOWER'S
REPORT AND HE PUT IT IN.
THEY SAID, NO, NO, IF THAT IS
THE CASE, IF YOU HAVE TO DO
THAT, WHAT WE WILL DO IS SHOW
YOU THE CALL.
NO, NO, NO, I DON'T WANT TO SEE
IT.
WHAT IS THAT ALL ABOUT?
WHY DID HE DO THAT?
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO INTERVIEW THE
WHY DID HE DO THAT?
>> Laura: ARE YOU WORRIED
ABOUT FUTURE PRESIDENTS AND WHAT
THEY WILL DO TO PRESIDENTS IN
THE FUTURE?
>> President Trump: I THINK
IMPEACHMENT IS AN UGLY WORD.
BUT CHEAP AND THE WORD
IMPEACHMENT.
NANCY PELOSI AND SCHIFF IS
CORRUPT.
THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS AND
REPEATS A CONVERSATION EXCEPT A
FRAUD.
HE MADE UP A CONVERSATION.
HE WAS TAKING MY CONVERSATION,
AND IT WAS TOTALLY WRONG.
AND HE KNEW IT.
HE SAID "DON'T CALL ME, I WILL
CALL YOU."
THAT IS FROM THE GODFATHER, THE
MAFIA STATEMENT.
I NEVER SAID THAT.
HE SAID EIGHT TIMES, QUID PRO
QUO.
IT WAS NO TIMES.
HE MADE UP A CONVERSATION AND
REPEATED IT IN FRONT OF
CONGRESS, AND BECAUSE HE HAS
IMMUNITY, WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT.
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY, WHY DID YOU
DO THAT?
THESE PEOPLE ARE FRAUDS.
THEY HAVE CHEAPEN THE WORD
IMPEACHMENT.
IT IS A BAD WORD TO START OFF
WITH.
IT IS AN UGLY WORD.
TO ME IT IS AN UGLY WORD.
BUT MAYBE IT PLAYED TO OUR
BENEFIT.
>> Laura: WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT NOW, IT LOOKS LIKE
McCONNELL IS AGREEING WITH
JOSH HAWLEY, THE PROPOSITION TO
DISMISS THESE ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT IF PELOSI DOES NOT
SEND THEM OVER.
MY QUESTION TO YOU, WHY NOT HAVE
THEM DISMISSED TODAY?
McCONNELL, WE ARE DONE WITH
THESE GAMES OR DO YOU WANT A
TRIAL?
>> President Trump: I WOULD
LOVE TO HAVE A TRIAL AND I WOULD
LOVE TO HAVE SLEEPY JOE BIDEN
COME I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE HIS
SON.
I CALL HIM, WHERE IS HUNTER?
I CHANGED HIS FIRST NAME TO
WHERE?
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER IS A PERSON
WHO YOU KNOW WHO THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER IS.
BY THE WAY, EVERYBODY KNOWS WHO
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER IS.
I DON'T WANT TO TAKE HIM BUT
EVERYBODY KNOWS ABOUT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
AND THEY KNOW ABOUT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER'S LAWYER.
BUT THEN YOU REMEMBER THERE WAS
A SECOND WHISTLE-BLOWER.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO
THE SECOND WHISTLE-BLOWER?
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE INFORMER?
THEY ALL DISAPPEARED WHEN I GAVE
THE TRANSCRIPT.
I GAVE A TRANSCRIPT, AND THAT
BLEW EVERYTHING APART.
WE HAVE AN ACCURATE -- AND THE
ONLY THING COVERED BY THE
HEARINGS IS THAT PEOPLE AGREE,
EVERYBODY, EVEN THE GREAT
LIEUTENANT COLONEL, PLEASE CALL
HIM LIEUTENANT COLONEL, GREAT
LIEUTENANT COLONEL AGREES THAT
THE TRANSCRIPT WAS ACCURATE.
I THINK HE HAD ONE WORD
DIFFERENT.
CHANGE THE ONE WORD WHICH MEANT
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
THE TRANSCRIPT WAS
PROFESSIONALLY DONE BY THE BEST
PEOPLE.
JUST ONE SECOND, SO WE HAVE A
TRANSCRIPT.
HE NEVER THOUGHT THAT I WOULD
RELEASE IT.
THEY PROBABLY THOUGHT I NEVER
HAD IT.
I ONLY SAY THANK GOODNESS I HAD
IT BECAUSE I WOULD HAVE BEEN
FALSELY ACCUSED, AND IT WOULD
HAVE SADLY BEEN MY WORD AGAINST
THEIRS.
WE HAD OTHER PEOPLE ON THAT
CALL.
THINK OF THIS.
I WAS GOING TO DO SOMETHING
WRONG ON A CALL WHERE I KNOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE LISTENING.
>> Laura: ALWAYS.
>> President Trump: THE
PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE SAID I DID
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING WRONG.
HE SAID I HAD NO PRESSURE
WHATSOEVER.
HE DIDN'T EVEN KNOW WHAT WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT.
WE CALLED THEM BEFORE I RELEASE
THE TRANSCRIPT BECAUSE IT IS A
TERRIBLE THING TO HAVE TO
RELEASE A CONVERSATION WITH A
LEADER FROM ANOTHER COUNTRY.
IT IS A TERRIBLE THING.
I MEAN, WHAT ARE OTHER COUNTRIES
OTHER THAN UKRAINE SAYING?
SO ANYWAY, THEY HAVE NO CASE.
>> Laura: WENT OUT CALL
JOHN BOLTON AND ALLOW HIM TO
TESTIFY?
THIS IS BOGUS.
>> GNOMIC >> President Trump:
YOU CAN'T BE ON THE WHITE HOUSE
AS PRESIDENT AND THE FUTURE, AND
HAVE A SECURITY ADVISOR, ANYONE
HAVING TO DEAL WITH SECURITY.
>> Laura: WILL YOU INVOKE
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE?
>> President Trump: I THINK
YOU HAVE TO FOR THE SAKE OF THE
OFFICE.
I WOULD LOVE EVERYBODY TO
TESTIFY.
I WOULD LIKE MICK MULVANEY TO
TESTIFY, MIKE POMPEO TO TESTIFY.
I LIKE RICK PERRY TO TESTIFY, I
WANT EVERYBODY.
BUT THERE ARE THINGS THAT YOU
CAN'T DO FROM THE STANDPOINT OF
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
YOU HAVE TO MAINTAIN THAT.
SO WE WILL SEE WHERE IT ALL
GOES.
BUT ESPECIALLY NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR, YOU CAN'T HAVE HIM
EXPLAINING ALL OF YOUR
STATEMENTS ABOUT NATIONAL
SECURITY CONCERNING RUSSIA,
CHINA, NORTH KOREA, EVERYTHING.
YOU JUST CAN'T DO THAT.
LOOK --
>> HOW ABOUT PELOSI?
>> President Trump: SHE WILL
GO DOWN AS THE LEAST SUCCESSFUL
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE IN THE
HISTORY OF THE NATION.
SHE'S DONE NOTHING.
THE ONLY THING SHE'S DONE, SHE
GOT DONE ONE OF THE BEST TRADE
DEALS THE COUNTRY HAS EVER MADE
THE USMCA WITH MEXICO AND
CANADA.
BUT I DID THAT.
SHE DOESN'T EVEN KNOW WHAT IT
SAYS.
SHE HAS NO IDEA WHAT IT SAYS.
SHE WAS FORCED TO DO THAT.
YOU KNOW WHY?
SHE WOULD NOT HAVE DONE IT BUT
SHE DID NOTHING.
SO NOW SHE CAN SAY I SIGN
SOMETHING.
SHE IS OBSESSED WITH
IMPEACHMENT.
SHE HAS DONE NOTHING.
SHE IS GOING TO GO DOWN AS ONE
OF THE WORST SPEAKERS IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
NOW, IN ALL FAIRNESS, SHE IS
HURTING OUR COUNTRY.
SHE IS VERY BAD FOR OUR COUNTRY.
AND SHE HAS BECOME A CRAZED
LUNATIC.
BUT SHE WILL GO DOWN AS, I
THINK, MAY BE THE WORST SPEAKER
IN THE HISTORY OF THE COUNTRY.
SHE WILL BE OVERTHROWN SOON.
SHE IS DOING VERY LITTLE AND THE
PEOPLE ARE TIRED OF IT.
SHE IS CONTROLLED BY THE RADICAL
LEFT.
SHE IS CONTROLLED BY AOC.
SHE IS CONTROLLED BY MISS TLAIB
ANOTHER GREAT ONE.
SHE IS CONTROLLED BY OMAR.
>> Laura: WE JUST HEARD THAT
THEY ARE THINKING ABOUT ADDING
ANOTHER ARTICLE OF IMPEACHMENT,
FLOATING THIS TO INCLUDE THE
EVENTS OF THE LAST FEW WEEKS.
HERE IS WHAT CHUCK SCHUMER JUST
SAID TO.
>> OVER THE PAST FEW WEEKS,
THERE HAVE BEEN SEVERAL CRUCIAL
DISCLOSURES OF EVIDENCE THAT
APPEARED TO FURTHER INCRIMINATE
THE PRESIDENT.
EACH DISCLOSURE BOLSTERING THE
ARGUMENT THAT WE DEMOCRATS HAVE
MADE FOR A TRIAL THAT FEATURES
THE RELEVANT WITNESSES AND
DOCUMENTS.
>> Laura: YOUR REACTION TO
POTENTIALLY ADDING TO ARTICLES
OF IMPEACHMENT THAT THEY STILL
HAVEN'T DELIVERED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR.
>> President Trump: SO THEY
CAN'T WIN AN ELECTION THAT WILL
TAKE PLACE IN TEN MONTHS.
THEY KNOW THAT AND THE ONLY
THING THEY CAN DO, IT'S LIKE THE
CONGRESSMAN GREEN WHEN HE SAID
"WE CAN'T BEAT HIM, WE HAVE TO
IMPEACH HIM" AND THEY ALL KNOW
THAT.
THEY ARE MAKING THINGS UP.
THIS IS THE CRAZIEST THING
ANYONE HAS EVER SEEN.
THE TWO ARTICLES THEY PUT IN AS
YOU KNOW, THEY ARE NOT PRIMES.
THEY ARE NOT EVEN ALLOWED TO BE
PUT IN.
IT IS A DISGRACE.
>> Laura: DOESN'T NOT SHOW THE
WEAKNESS OF THEIR CASE BUT THEY
ARE STILL TRYING TO REBRAND THIS
AS SOMETHING ELSE?
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS.
>> President Trump: I THINK IT
IS INCREDIBLE.
I THINK IT IS REALLY HURTING
THEM.
MY NUMBERS IS THE HIGHEST IN
POLL NUMBERS.
YOU HAVE THIS GUY THAT WAS ON
TELEVISION WITH PHONY NUMBERS,
BUT AS YOU KNOW MY POLL NUMBERS
AS OF TODAY ARE THE HIGHEST THEY
HAVE EVER BEEN AND BY THE WAY,
PEOPLE LOVE THAT WE TOOK OUT
THIS HORRIBLE TERRORIST.
THEY LOVE IT, SOLEIMANI, THEY
LEFT THAT WE TOOK HIM OUT.
THEY THINK IT IS SO FANTASTIC.
HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN TAKEN OUT
THE LAST 20 YEARS BY SOMEONE.
HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN TAKEN OUT A
LONG TIME AGO.
MY NUMBERS ARE THE HIGHEST THEY
HAVE EVER BEEN.
A LOT OF IT HAS BEEN BECAUSE OF
THE IMPEACHMENT HOAX, IT IS A
HOAX.
HOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE TWO,
TWO AND HALF YEARS UNDER
INVESTIGATION, FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION BEFORE I EVEN RAN
IN MY OPINION, BEFORE I CAME
DOWN THE ESCALATOR.
BUT FROM THE TIME I CAME DOWN
THE ESCALATOR, I HAVE BEEN UNDER
INVESTIGATION.
THEY FOUND NOTHING.
WHO ELSE DO YOU THINK AND
WASHINGTON --
>> Laura: NO ONE COULD HAVE
WITHSTOOD IT.
>> President Trump: NOT ONLY
WITHSTOOD IT MENTALLY.
>> Laura: ACCOMPLISHED.
>> President Trump: IT MAKES
ME ANGRY.
BUT THINK WHO ELSE COULD HAVE
WITHSTOOD THAT?
YOU TAKE SOME OF THESE DEMOCRAT